what does by let's assume we are asked
to draw a circle of radius three
centimeters so we draw a circle like
this the length of this red thing will
be the parameter and we have a special
name for the parameter of a circle it's
called the circumference this length
will be the circumference this length
will measure eighteen point eight five
centimeters the next thing we need to
find out is the diameter of the circle
the diameter of a circle is twice its
radius hence the diameter will be 2
multiplied by three which equals six
centimeters now we've been asked to draw
a circle of radius four centimeters it
will be slightly bigger than the
previous one this red boundary will be
the circumference this time two we
measure the circumference for this
circle we get the circumference as 25.1
centimeters and the diameter will be
twice its radius which equals eight
centimeters we looked at two different
cases here one circle with three as the
radius and another with four as its
radius in both cases we calculated the
circumference and the diameter let's
zoom out and find the ratio of
circumference by diameter in each case
if we calculate the value of
circumference by diameter in the first
case we will approximately get it as
3.14 and guess what in the second case
two we get the value of circumference by
diameter as approximately 3.14 no matter
what circle you look at the value of
circumference by diameter will always be
approximately equal to 3.14 this value
is pi remember both these values are
approximations now let's zoom out and
deduce a formula for the circumference
as the circumference by diameter equals
pi we can say that the circumference of
a circle equals pi
applied by the diameter if we call the
diameter D then the formula can be
written as pi multiplied by D which can
also be written as pi multiplied by 2 R
because the diameter is twice the radius
so the circumference of a circle is
written as 2 PI R all we did was write
this product a bit differently this is a
very important formula as it gives us
the value of the circumference even if
you just have the radius of the circle
there's another important thing about
this special constant pi we get the same
value if we divide 22 by 7 so the value
of pi approximately equals 3.14 or 22 by
7 but why do we use this symbol for pi
what is this symbol pi is actually the
16th letter of the Greek alphabet but
the question still remains why the 16th
letter we just saw that pi has got
something to do with the perimeter or
the circumference of the circle let's
use Google Translate to see the Greek
equivalent of perimeter as we can see
the first letter of the greek word is pi
let's try a couple of more words related
to perimeter how about periphery the
first letter is still pi hmm okay let's
try circumference the first letter as
all of us can see is still pi that's
probably why the symbol was used to
denote by anyway don't forget the
important point pi is the circumference
of the circle divided by its diameter so
it is the ratio of the circumference to
the diameter based on the formula if the
diameter of the circle is 1 unit then
its circumference will be pi units if we
have a circle like this with diameter
equal to 1 unit then the length of this
boundary will be pi or approximately 3
point one four units